bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du stoïcisme
vous commencez à connaître mon intérêt
pour le stoïcisme
c'est une philosophie dont je vous ai
déjà parlé à plusieurs reprises et qui
selon moi mérite d'être promu
parce que c'est une philosophie pratique
parce que c'est une philosophie qui ne
nécessite pas d'avoir un bagage
particulier en philosophie pour la
comprendre
et parce que ces enseignements
s'adressent à tous
il y a des philosophes qui parlent de
choses qui n'intéressent pas grand monde
ou en tout cas qui en parle dans des
termes qui peuvent ne pas raisonner en
nous
alors que les stoïciens au contraire
nous parlent de choses familières
ils nous parlent des émotions du désir
de la déception de la souffrance
bref de toutes ces choses qui jalonnent
notre quotidien et que pour beaucoup
nous ne questionnons plus
parce que nous les avons intégrés
nous avons intégré la souffrance nous
avons intégré la déception et le regret
nous les avons normalisés
selon l'idée que si ces choses font
partie de notre vie
ces qu'elles doivent faire partie de la
vie
et que donc on ne peut rien y changer
et bien ce que nous disent les stoïciens
c'est qu'on peut échanger quelque chose
qu'on peut même faire changer
radicalement les choses
mais ça implique de commencer par en
prendre conscience
quand on évolue dans le stress
émotionnel
quand on évolue dans la frustration dans
la colère dans toutes ces émotions
négatives et conscient
on finit par les épouser
on finit par se confondre avec elle
un peu comme on s'habitue à la gravité
quand vous marchez vous ne vous dites
pas que vous évoluez dans la gravité
mais si vous tombez du quatrième étage
vous allez vous en rendre compte
et bien c'est la même chose avec les
émotions
on s'y habitue on les normalise au point
de ne plus s'en rendre compte
ce que nous disent les stoïciens c'est
que non
la souffrance n'a pas à être normalisée
non la déception et le regret n'ont pas
à être normalisés
aucune émotion négative et même aucune
émotion tout court n'a à être normalisé
parce que nos émotions nous pouvons nous
en libérer
alors je précise que les stoïciens
n'utilisaient pas le mot émotion
il parlait de passion
on est en antiquité le vocabulaire
n'était pas exactement le même
et les passions contrairement à l'image
qu'on s'en fait aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas quelque chose de positif
passion du grec pathos c'est ce qu'on
subit
la passion nous rend passif
et le pathos c'est en même temps la
souffrance
la douleur de l'âme
et donc quand je dis que pour les
stoïciens nous pouvons nous libérer de
nos émotions
il faut évidemment prendre le temps
d'expliquer
parce que j'entends d'ici les personnes
qui vont dire comment ça on peut se
libérer de ses émotions
mais les émotions ça ne se contrôle pas
une émotion on la constate
on y assiste
on en est pas responsable
parce qu'on n'est pas responsable de sa
sensibilité
et bien c'est là qu'il va falloir donner
quelques explications
pour les stoïciens nous sommes
responsables de nos émotions parce que
nos émotions sont le produit du jugement
du jugement que nous portons sur le
monde
du jugement que nous portons sur les
autres
et du jugement que nous portons sur
nous-mêmes
en clair pour les stoïciens se libérer
des émotions et de la souffrance qui en
découle ça passe par
se libérer du jugement
on va partir d'une citation d'Epictète
je rappelle que c'était un stoïcien qui
avait la particularité d'être un esclave
d'ailleurs le nom Epictète signifie
serviteur en grec
épithète disait ce qui trouble les
hommes ce ne sont pas les choses mais
les jugements qu'ils portent sur les
choses
l'air de rien cette phrase résume tout
maintenant on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi il dit ça
dire que ce qui nous trouble ce ne sont
pas les choses mais les jugements
comportent sur les choses
c'est dire que les choses pourraient ne
pas nous affecter
mais que nous acceptons qu'elle nous a
faite
autrement dit que nous laissons les
choses nous affecter parce que nous
placons sur elle des jugements
et que ce sont ces jugements qui sont la
cause réelle de notre souffrance
prenons un cas concret
imaginez qu'un ami vous trahisse
vous pouvez imaginer n'importe quel type
de scénario
ils bavent sur vous derrière votre dos
il vous vole de l'argent
il drague votre fiancé bref vous
imaginez ce que vous voulez
maintenant imaginez que vous apprenez
que cet ami vous a trahi
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que vous allez
éprouver
ben si vous êtes à peu près comme tout
le monde vous allez lui en vouloir
vous allez éprouver de la colère
peut-être même de la rage
de la haine
cette colère viendra non seulement du
Thor qu'il vous aura causé mais aussi de
la déception
un ami c'est quelqu'un qui on a
confiance
c'est quelqu'un vis-à-vis de qui on a
des attentes
par définition on peut être trahi que
par quelqu'un en qui on a investi notre
confiance
et cette colère va vous ronger
cette colère va vous consumer de
l'intérieur
vous allez souffrir
vous allez serrer les dents serrez les
points
et si vous vous laissez aller à votre
colère vous allez souder à sa porte et
lui faire comprendre en langage des
signes que c'était une erreur de vous
faire ça
dans tous les cas le résultat de cette
trahison ça va être une réaction
émotionnelle
à ce moment-là si quelqu'un vient vous
voir en vous disant non mais tu sais tu
souffres mais en réalité ce n'est pas de
la faute de ton ami
ce n'est pas cette trahison qui te fait
souffrir
c'est le jugement que tu t'en fais
le seul responsable de ta colère c'est
toi-même
vous allez vous dire
mais sous moi
bien sûr que si c'est sa faute
bien sûr que si c'est ça trahison qui me
fait souffrir
moi je n'ai rien fait
et bien si
vous avez fait quelque chose
pour les stoïciens c'est vous le
responsable de votre souffrance
parce que vous avez attendu de cet ami
qu'il se comporte d'une manière que vous
n'étiez pas en mesure de maîtriser
si votre ami vous a trahi
vous n'y êtes pour rien
ce choix ne relève pas de votre volonté
c'est son choix à lui
or être affecté parce qu'il ne dépend
pas de nous c'est ce condamné au malheur
on va prendre un autre exemple qui va
nous permettre d'y voir plus clair
imaginons que vous jouiez au loto
vous jouez au loto en vous disant bon on
sait jamais
avec un peu de chance je vais finir
millionnaire
donc vous jouez
le tirage au sort a lieu et vous perdez
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que vous allez
ressentir
un peu de déception c'est normal
personne ne joue pour perdre
mais en réalité cette déception elle va
pas vous affecter très longtemps
ni de manière très intense
parce qu'au fond de vous vous saviez que
vous aviez peu de chance de gagner
vous ne lisez pas votre avenir là-dessus
vous auriez gagné vous auriez été
extrêmement content
mais dans le cas contraire c'est pas si
grave
pourquoi
parce que vous saviez dès le départ que
vos chances de gagner étaient faibles
et donc votre réaction sera à la hauteur
de la probabilité qui était la vôtre de
gagner
faible probabilité de gagner égale
faible attente égale faible déception
donc en réalité c'est l'attente qui
génère la déception
si votre attente est faible votre
déception aussi sera faible
si votre attente est importante
votre déception le sera tout autant
maintenant revenons-en au cas de votre
ami qui vous a trahi
ce qui vous a fait
ce n'est pas que votre ami vous êtes
trahi
c'est que vous ne vous attendiez pas à
ce qu'il vous trahisse
vous aviez vis-à-vis de lui une attente
de loyauté
une attente de fidélité au sens
étymologique de fidèles la foi
et donc lorsque vous apprenez que cette
attente n'est pas satisfaite
vous souffrez
c'est donc bien l'attente que vous aviez
placée en lui qui est la cause de votre
souffrance
un ennemi il n'y a rien de surprenant à
ce qui nous trahissent
c'est même la moindre des choses
le problème de la trahison ne se pose
qu'avec des personnes en qui on a
confiance
ce sont toujours nos proches qui nous
trahissent
par extension ce sont toujours nos
proches qui nous font le plus souffrir
parce qu'on place en eux des attentes
et que ce sont ces attentes qui nous
reviennent en pleine figure lorsqu'elles
ne sont pas remplies par la personne en
qui on a confiance
c'est donc bien que le problème ne vient
pas de la personne mais de nos attentes
envers la personne
la trahison ne nous fait souffrir que
parce qu'on juge que la trahison d'un
ami est quelque chose d'inadmissible
maintenant que nous disent les stoïciens
et nous disent que nous sommes
responsables de l'attente que nous avons
placé dans notre ami
nous lui avons fait confiance nous avons
cru littéralement dans sa loyauté
mais cette croyance n'engageait que nous
je rappelle à l'instant que l'étymologie
de confiance c'était fidèle
la foi
la confiance est toujours une affaire de
foi
pourquoi avons-nous confiance
parce qu'on sent qu'on peut faire
confiance
alors oui il y a des cas où la personne
nous a prouvé qu'on pouvait lui faire
confiance
qu'on pouvait
pas qu'on devait
parce qu'on ne sait jamais si on a eu
raison de faire confiance à quelqu'un
avant que ce quelqu'un ne trahisse cette
confiance
on ne sait jamais
donc tout attente est basé sur de la
projection
sur de la projection qui ne nous
appartient pas de maîtriser
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il ne faut
plus faire confiance à personne
non
ça veut dire que si vous faites
confiance à quelqu'un
vous devez vous attendre à ce que cette
personne trahisse votre confiance
ce que ça arrive
ce que c'est dans l'ordre des choses
parce que l'être humain n'est pas pur
qui lui arrive de trahir qui lui arrive
de commettre des fautes
et vous n'y pouvez rien
croire que la personne en qui vous avez
confiance ne vous trahira jamais
c'est ça la faute
parce que c'est partir du principe que
l'être humain pourrait être infaillible
mais vous savez pertinemment que l'être
humain n'est pas infaillible
donc pourquoi attendre de l'être humain
qu'il se comporte comme aucun être
humain ne peut se comporter
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas là la faute
est-ce que la faute ce n'est pas d'avoir
les attentes inatteignables
est-ce que la faute ce n'est pas de ne
pas avoir compris ce qui était la
réalité
alors bien sûr face à ce discours vont
se dresser les discours idéalistes et
moralisateurs
mais comment peut-on dire ça
la confiance c'est fondamentale
il faudrait donc tout accepter tout
tolérer
c'est ça le modèle des stoïciens
non ce n'est pas ça le modèle des
stoïciens
le modèle des stoïciens c'est de dire
qu'on n'a jamais raison contre la
réalité
or la réalité c'est que la trahison
existe
la réalité c'est que l'être humain est
animé par des forces qui ne sont pas
toujours des forces morales
l'être humain est animé par l'ego
par le désir de pouvoir
par l'intérêt
et qu'on aura beau chanté des sérénades
à la gloire de la vertu c'était pas ça
qui rendra l'être humain plus vertueux
l'être humain est-ce qu'il est
il a ses qualités et ses défauts et en
plaquant sur l'être humain des attentes
morales et idéales on se condamne à la
déception
en se condamne au malheurs
Marc Aurèle disait dès l'aurore dis toi
d'avance je vais rencontrer un indiscret
un grain un insolent un fourbe un
envieux un égoïste
pourquoi Marc Aurèle disait-il ça
parce qu'il considérait que tous les
êtres humains étaient immoraux
non
ce qu'il considérait que ces choses là
existaient
pas qu'elles étaient systématiques
pas qu'il n'existait aucune vertu chez
les êtres humains
mais parce que l'être humain n'est pas
constitué seulement de vertus
elle est là la nuance
quand on a des attentes envers quelqu'un
on projette sur lui un idéal
un idéal dont on sait pertinemment quand
on connaît un peu la nature humaine qui
n'est pas atteignable
mais tout le problème se situe dans le
quand on connaît la nature humaine
pas quand on idéalise la nature humaine
pas quand on fantasme la nature humaine
la grande leçon du stoïcisme c'est là le
son tu réalises
du réalisme qui nous fait comprendre et
accepter qu'on peut pas attendre de
l'être humain ce qui n'est pas en
capacité d'atteindre
tu réalisme qui doit nous inciter à la
prudence
à la prémunition
qui nous fait comprendre et accepter que
si on attend de l'être humain ce qui
n'est pas en mesure d'atteindre on va
souffrir
et que ça ne sert à rien de rejeter la
faute sur l'autre
parce que premièrement ça ne changera
rien à la situation
deuxièmement ça ne fera que nous
enfermer dans le déni
notre problème ce n'est pas que l'être
humain se comporte en être humain
avec ses défauts ses failles et ces
vices
notre problème c'est que nous attendons
de l'être humain qu'il se comporte comme
s'il n'était pas un être humain
comme s'il n'était pas soumis aux
défauts aux failles et aux vices
il est là le problème
le problème vient de nos attentes
le problème vient de notre jugement
et de notre désir que la nature humaine
se conforme à notre jugement alors que
ça devrait être l'inverse
ce n'est pas à la nature humaine de se
conformer à notre jugement sur la nature
humaine
c'est un autre jugement de se conformer
à ce qu'est la nature humaine
c'est ça la clé
accepter l'être humain tel qu'il est
pour ne pas en être déçu
pour ne pas nourrir des attentes
inatteignables
et vous aurez beau dire tout ce que vous
voudrez
vous aurez beau maudire la nature
humaine dire que les gens sont méchants
ou décevants ça ne changera rien
la seule question est
êtes-vous prêts à changer vos attentes
vis-à-vis de l'être humain
êtes-vous prêts à admettre que vos
attentes vis-à-vis de l'être humain ne
proviennent pas de l'observation de la
nature humaine
mais d'un idéal que vous projetez sur
elle
C'est ça la vraie question
le reste c'est du blabla
le reste c'est du prétexte pour ne pas
avoir à modifier votre jugement de ce
que devrait être la nature humaine
et c'est en ça que vous êtes responsable
de vos émotions
vous êtes responsable de vos émotions
parce que vos émotions dépendent non pas
de la réalité de la nature humaine mais
du jugement sur ce que devrait être la
nature humaine
le problème ce n'est pas la réalité
c'est le jugement sur la réalité
quand Marc Aurèle fait la liste des
défauts humains ce n'est pas pour dire
que tous les êtres humains sont
nécessairesment méchant ou hostiles
c'est pour dire qu'il faut s'attendre à
retrouver ses défauts chez l'être humain
parce que ses défauts sont constitutifs
de la nature humaine
et qu'attendre de l'être humain qu'il ne
soit pas l'être humain c'est insensé
c'est insensé et c'est parce que c'est
insensé que ça nous rend malheureux
ce qui rend malheureux ce ne sont pas
les choses
ce ne sont pas les choses telles
qu'elles sont
c'est l'écart entre les choses telles
qu'elles sont et les choses telles qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit
telle qu'on les imagine
telles qu'on les idéalise
tels qu'on les juges
il est là le problème
dans notre jugement
tout le problème vient de notre jugement
sur les choses
les stoïciens disent il y a ce qui
dépend de nous il y a ce qui ne dépend
pas de nous
être affecté par ce qui ne dépend pas de
nous c'est insensé
parce que c'est croire que ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous pourrait dépendre de
nous
c'est croire que nous pourrions avoir
une influence sur ce qui ne dépend pas
de nous
c'est irrationnel
les stoïciens prônent la raison
il prône la conformité au logos
les lois logiques
auxquelles sont adossées les lois de la
nature
s'il pleut vous n'allez pas pleurer
vous allez prendre un parapluie
s'il fait froid vous n'allez pas pleurer
vous allez vous couvrir
en d'autres termes face à une situation
vous allez vous adapter
parce que vous savez que vous ne pouvez
pas demander au ciel toute façon
vous savez que ça ne dépend pas de vous
ce qui dépend de vous c'est de vous
prémunir contre les intempéries
c'est de faire en sorte
d'amortir les effets du réel sur vous
alors pourquoi devrait-il en être
autrement pour l'être humain
pourquoi l'être humain devrait-il se
conformer à vos attentes
à ce que vous espérez de lui
ça marche pas comme ça
et vous savez
donc si vous le savez pourquoi continuer
à vivre et à agir comme si vous ne
saviez pas
pourquoi continuer à être déçu par
quelqu'un qui ne se conforme pas à votre
vision de ce qu'il devrait être
avez-vous oublié que les êtres humains
sont régis par des motivations qui leur
sont propres
avez-vous oublié que les êtres humains
n'attendent pas de savoir ce que vous
pensez d'eux pour faire ce qu'ils
estiment avoir à faire
pour qui vous prenez-vous
c'est ça au fond la question que vous
pose les stoïciens
pour qui vous prenez vous pour croire
que la réalité va s'adapter à vous
c'est à vous de vous adapter à la
réalité
et si vous ne faites pas vous ne pouvez
vous en prendre qu'à vous-même
si vous êtes malheureux parce que vous
n'avez pas pris en compte la réalité
telle qu'elle est
la faute n'en revient pas à la réalité
la faute en revient à vous
la réalité elle est
c'est son boulot
votre boulot à vous
c'est de comprendre cette réalité
et de vous y adapter
de l'accepter
pas de projeter sur elle ce que vous
aimeriez qu'elle soit
pas de lui faire endosser le poids de
vos propres attentes
donc l'alternative est simple
l'acceptation ou le malheur
accepter ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
pour ne pas être malheureux
pour ne pas faire dépendre notre bonheur
de ce qui ne dépend pas de nous
on est habitué au jugement
on est habitué à dire ce qui est bien et
ce qui est mal
à dire ce que les autres devraient ou ne
devraient pas faire
on est d'ailleurs beaucoup plus pro à
dire ce qui ne va pas chez les autres
qu'à dire ce qui ne va pas chez nous
parce que nous voyons le monde à travers
nos propres schémas de perception
le prisme de notre propre conscience
partant de là tout ce qui ne correspond
pas à notre propre mode de
fonctionnement sera disqualifié
l'altérité nous échappe
même chez ceux qui se prétendent ouverts
et tolérant
ce n'est pas vrai que nous soyons
ouverts et tolérants
nous sommes sectaires
foncièrement sectaire
dès que quelque chose nous déplaît nous
nous empressons le juger
pas de le comprendre
pas d'essayer de le comprendre
de le juger
il ne faudrait pas faire comme si il
faudrait faire comme ça
et à chaque fois que nous jugeons ce qui
nous déplaît c'est comme si on
s'infligeait
un coup de canif dans notre modèle de
représentation
on s'énerve on s'indigne
on se scandalise
et se faisant
on se fait souffrir
au lieu de simplement nous dire
c'est comme ça
et si c'est comme ça c'est qu'il y a une
raison
les gens sont ce qu'ils sont
ils agissent comme ils agissent
ils pensent comme ils pensent
et c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave dès lors qu'on ne
cherche pas à plaquer sur l'autre nos
propres jugements
alors bien sûr il y a des fois où on
sait qu'on a raison
et où l'autre ne veut pas l'entendre
des fois où on sait que l'autre est dans
l'erreur
qu'ils ne s'en rend pas compte
parce que sa sensibilité ou son
expérience
ne l'ont pas fourni les clés de
compréhension
mais nous on sait
et parce qu'on sait on veut le faire
savoir
on veut faire savoir à l'autre qu'on
sait qu'on sait mieux que lui
et s'il ne l'entend pas ça nous dérange
là encore ce n'est pas tant ce que fait
l'autre qui nous dérange
c'est le jugement qu'on s'en fait
un ami qui se fait exploiter à son
travail
et qui ne s'en rend pas compte
on a envie de lui dire
réveille-toi
révolte toi
un ami qui est malheureux dans son
couple
dont on sait qu'il devrait mettre un
terme à sa relation
parce qu'on voit bien que c'est sans
issue
réveille-toi
révolte toi
et ça ne sert à rien
c'est toujours après coup que les
conseils résonne en nous
quand on a compris
vous pouvez juger comme il vous plaira
la situation de votre ami
vous pouvez lui conseiller ce que vous
voulez
la question est de savoir
à quel point le jugement que vous portez
sur votre ami
vous affecte-t-il vous
à quel point le fait de ne pas être
écouté
de ne pas être entendu
vous fait-il souffrir vous
C'est ça la vraie question
votre souffrance
la souffrance
issue de votre jugement
on va prendre un autre exemple
vous marchez dans la rue
vous glissez sur un pavé
et vous tombez
fort heureusement vous ne vous êtes pas
blessé
mais tout le monde vous a vu
tout le monde vous a vu vous mettre les
quatre phares en l'air
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que vous allez
éprouver
de la honte
ou tout du moins de la gêne
votre souffrance n'est pas tant physique
que morale
c'est votre dignité qui s'est fait mal
et pourquoi votre dignité s'est fait mal
parce que le jugement des autres sur
vous vous affecte
parce que vous vous dites j'ai l'air con
et avoir l'air c'est très important
c'est dans un monde d'hypocrisie qu'on
prétend que le regard des autres ne nous
atteint pas
bien sûr qu'il nous attend
bien sûr qu'on veut donner aux autres la
meilleure image de nous-mêmes
le nier c'est nier la réalité
la réalité de l'ego qui veut gouverner
notre image de soi
la morale de cette histoire c'est que de
la même façon que c'est le jugement qui
nous affecte plutôt que les événements
c'est le jugement des autres qui nous
affectent
plutôt que la situation concrète que
nous vivons devant eux
parce qu'on se projette dans leur
conscience
on pense à leur place
et on imagine ce qui doivent se dire
et c'est très important ce qu'il se
disent
rappelez-vous quand vous étiez au
collège et que vous deviez passer devant
toute la classe pour faire un exposé
dans cette situation beaucoup d'entre
vous étaient en panique
parce qu'il se disait qu'est-ce qu'on va
penser de moi
qu'est-ce que les autres vont se dire
et le stress émotionnel qu'on ressent
quand on se sent observé quand on se
sent scruter
c'est le stress du jugement
d'un jugement qui n'est pas tant le
jugement réel de ceux qui nous observent
que le jugement qu'on projette sur ce
qui nous observent
c'est ça l'ironie du jugement
ce qui nous affecte même quand il
n'existe pas
c'est qu'il nous affecte dès lors que
c'est nous qui le faisons exister
le problème du jugement
c'est nous
que les gens pensent ce qu'ils pensent
concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça va changer
qu'est-ce que ça va changer à part ce
que nous acceptons que ça change
pourquoi des jugements c'est à dire des
choses immatérielles des choses qui
n'ont pas de prise directe sur nous
peuvent-ils nous affecter
nous stresser
nous déranger
nous attrister
parce que nous les faisons exister
alors que dès qu'on rationalise
dès qu'on se met réellement à la place
de cet autre sur lequel on plaque des
jugements imaginaires
on se rend bien compte que tout ça c'est
de la pure projection
quand vous faisiez votre exposé la
plupart des élèves
ils pensaient à autre chose
à ce qu'ils avaient fait la veille ou à
ce qu'ils allaient faire après les cours
tout le monde s'en fiche
tout le monde s'en fiche de vous
la plus grande quantité de jugement sur
vous qui est jamais été accumulé
c'est la vôtre
c'est votre jugement sur vous-même qui a
le plus empoisonné votre existence
pas celui des autres
et vous le savez
donc la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi continuer d'accorder de la
valeur au jugement des autres
pourquoi continuer d'accorder de
l'importance à quelque chose qui n'a
d'impact que celui que vous consentez à
lui accorder
C'est ça la vraie question
donc pour les stoïciens notre souffrance
émotionnelle le stress la honte
l'inquiétude
tout ça
c'est nous qui ensemble responsables
c'est dans notre tête
rien ne peut vous affecter
émotionnellement que vous n'ayez
consenti à vous laisser affecter
et quand vous faites l'état des lieux
quand vous comparez ce qui vous est
arrivé à vos réactions à ce qui vous
êtes arrivé
vous allez voir du premier coup d'oeil
de quel côté penche la balance
elle penche du côté de la réaction
elle penche du côté de l'amplification
par le jugement
ça la réalité
et ça marche pour tout
les gens ne vous aiment pas
OK
et donc
ça change quoi
ça change quoi pour vous
concrètement
tout se situe dans le concrètement
concrètement ça veut dire sanctionne
soit une production de votre mental
sans que ce ne soit une pure
construction de votre esprit
et crucial comme différence
parce que c'est la différence entre ce
qui vous concerne est-ce qu'il vous
concerne pas
c'est la différence entre ce qui vous
atteint par la force des choses et ce
qui vous attend parce que vous avez
accepté que ça vous atteigne
la différence c'est vous
donc si on résume
il y a le jugement que vous portez sur
les situations
et qui vous affecte davantage que les
situations elles-mêmes
et il y a le jugement des autres ou
plutôt le jugement que vous projetez sur
les autres
et qui vous affectent davantage que ce
pourquoi vous pensez qu'il vous juge
dans les deux cas ce qui vous affecte
c'est le jugement
ce qui vous a fait
ce sont des projections mentales
des projections mentales qui soient ne
changeront rien à la situation
qui ne feront que rendre douloureuse une
situation qui ne le serait pas sans
votre jugement
ou soit qui projettent sur les autres un
jugement qui n'est le fruit que de votre
imagination
et qui vous affecte en retour par pur
effet boomerang
comme si on construisait soi-même les
raisons de sa propre souffrance mentale
donc la leçon des stoïciens c'est que
nous devons épouser ce qui nous arrive
nous devons ne faire qu'un avec ce qui
arrive
parce que le jugement nous dissocie
il nous dissocie de la réalité
et il nous dissocie de nous-mêmes
et nous dissocie de cette capacité à
recevoir les choses telles qu'elles sont
à accepter plutôt qu'à réagir
à vivre plutôt qu'à juger
je cite
parmi les choses les unes dépendent de
nous les autres n'en dépentent pas
celles qui dépend de nous c'est
l'opinion le vouloir le désir la version
en un mot tout ce qui est notre œuvre
celle qui ne dépendent pas de nous c'est
le corps les biens la réputation les
dignités en un mot tout ce qui n'est pas
notre œuvre et les choses qui dépendent
de nous sont par nature libre nul ne
peut les empêcher rien ne peut les
entraver mais celles qui ne dépendent
pas de nous sont impuissantes esclaves
sujettes à empêchement étrangère à nous
souviens-toi donc que si tu crois libre
ces choses qui de leur nature sont
esclaves et propres à toi celles qui
sont étrangères tu sauras entravé
affligé troubler tu accuseras Dieu et
homme mais si tu crois tiens c'est la
seule qui est tient et étranger ce qui
en effet était étranger nul ne te
forcera jamais à faire une chose nul ne
t'en empêchera
tu ne te plaindras de personne tu
n'accuseras personne tu ne feras pas
involontairement une seule action
personne ne te Nua et d'ennemis tu n'en
n'aura point car tu ne pourras pas même
souffrir rien de nuisible aussitôt donc
devant toute imagination pénible
exerce-toi à dire tu es imagination et
apparence nullement l'objet que tu
paraît être ensuite sont de là et juge
là avec les règles que tu possèdes la
première est la principale c'est de voir
s'il s'agit des choses qui dépendent de
nous ou de celles qui n'en dépendent pas
s'agit-il de ces dernières soit prêt à
dire il n'y a rien là qui me regarde moi
souviens-toi que ce qu'on se promet dans
le désir c'est d'obtenir l'objet désiré
ce qu'on se promet dans la version c'est
d'éviter l'objet en aversion et celui
qui est frustré dans son désir et
malheureux celui qui tombe dans ce qu'il
fuit misérable fut donc seulement les
choses qui dépendant de toi sont
contraires la nature est une tomberas
point dans ce que tu fuis mais si tu
veux éviter la maladie ou la mort ou la
pauvreté tu seras misérable écarte donc
ton aversion de toutes les choses qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et reporte là sur
des choses qui dépendent de nous sont
contraires à la nature quant au désir
supprime-le tout à fait en ce moment car
si tu désires quelcune de ces choses qui
ne dépendent pas de nous tu seras
nécessairement malheureux et d'un autre
côté parmi les choses qui dépend de nous
et qu'il serait beau de désirer aucune
pour toi n’est encore présente bornes
toi donc à t'approcher ou à t'éloigner
des choses par un mouvement volontaire
mais peu énergique avec des réserves et
en modérant ton élan ce qui trouble les
hommes ce ne sont pas les choses mais
les jugements qui portent sur les choses
par exemple la mort n'est rien de
terrible car Socrate aussi l'aurait
trouvé terrible mais notre opinion sur
la mort qui nous l'a fait regarder comme
terrible
voilà ce qui est terrible alors donc que
nous sommes entravés ou troublés ou
affligés n'accusons jamais autrui mais
nous-mêmes c'est-à-dire nos opinions
œuvres d'ignorant que d'accuser les
autres de ses propres mots l'homme qui
commence à s'instruire s'accuse lui-même
l'homme instruit ni les autres niçois ne
t'en orgueilli de nul avantage étrangers
si le cheval s'enorgueillissant disait
je suis beau ce serait supportable mais
toi quand tu dis avec orgueil j'ai un
beau cheval sache que c'est des qualités
d'un cheval que tu t'en orgueilles qu'y
a-t-il donc là de tiens l'usage que tu
fais de tes représentations aussi
lorsque tu te serviras de ces
représentations conformément à la nature
alors seulement soit fier car tu sauras
fier d'un bien qui t'es propre n'attend
pas que les choses arrivent comme tu le
souhaites décide de vouloir ce qui
arrive et tu sauras heureux
les stoïciens passe très souvent pour
des philosophes inhumains
des philosophes qui n’iraient notre
dimension émotionnelle
et qui nous encouragerait à nous couper
de tout sentiment
de tout lien affectif avec l'être humain
la mort ne doit pas affecter
car elle est une chose inévitable et
naturelle
la trahison ne doit pas affecter
car elle est une chose inévitable et
naturelle
la honte et le regret ne doivent pas
affecter
car ce sont là des choses
inévitables et naturelles
mais alors
qu'est-ce qui doit nous affecter
pour les stoïciens seul doit nous
affecter
ce qui dépend de nous
pas avant pas après
pendant
agir au moment où nous devons agir
avec toute notre attention
avec toutes
notre concentration
agir en pleine présence
sans projection mentale
sans peur du jugement
mais avec la conviction de faire ce qui
est juste
parce que nous n'en porterons rien dans
la tombe
rien
si ce n'est
la satisfaction
d'avoir bien vécu
je vous remercie
[Musique]